voici trois espèces animales disparues à
cause de l'homme 1 le tigre de java
cette sous-espèce de tigre vivaient
autrefois sur l'île de java en indonésie
il a été chassé de son habitat naturel
par l'activité humaine pour laisser
place à des rizières ou des plantations
de café ce tir aux rayures fines
disparaît définitivement au début des
années 80 2 le grizzly de californie
cette sous-espèce d'ours braqué pourtant
éteinte depuis 1924 ce sont les
nombreuses à taille de grizzly revers
les hommes où le bétail qui ont poussé
les colons à les chasser 3 le dos de
l'animal emblématique de l'île maurice
est l'une des premières espèces animales
dont l'extinction est directement lié à
l'activité humaine découverte en
1598 l'espèce est considérée comme
éteinte moins d'un siècle après sa
découverte ce sont les animaux
introduits par l'homme qui sont à
l'origine de cette disparition et la
déforestation n'a rien arrangé